[Musique]
je dirige un type d'établissement tout
spécialement conçu pour accueillir deux
jeunes personnes comme toi une courte
période d'acclimatation pourrait être
nécessaire mais tu verras que la paix et
la sérénité n'ont pas leur pareil pour
apaiser les esprits comme il est dit
dans la sainte bible
seul le contact avec la nature permet à
l'homme de redevenir pur
je crois que tu intégrera très bien
c'est quoi ces bêtes de cirque pourquoi
tu et à toi parce que mes parents m'ont
menti
à des parents ils m'ont dit que c'était
pour le nouveau semestre le dr sherman
s'est fixé pour but d'atteindre la
clarté dans les deux prochaines semaines
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre et il
n'est pas question que je fréquente cet
établissement vous n'avez pas le choix
mademoiselle vous le trompe
[Musique]
on reprend la place à présent il faut
pour ce tir d'ici
[Musique]
les dr sherman vous enseigner une leçon
aujourd'hui j'espère que vous écoutiez
[Musique]